in Atlanta today a judge plans to
release part of a special grand jury
report on efforts by former president
Trump and his allies to overturn
Georgia's 2020 election results any
recommendations on criminal charges will
remain secret for now Robert Costa is in
Atlanta to show us what to expect from
the highly anticipated move Bob good
morning
good morning to you Nate by a judge's
order we will see the report's
introduction and conclusion later today
we will also see a section where jurors
Express concern that some witnesses
might have lied under oath but we are
still on watch for the District
Attorney's final decision
after seven months of investigating part
of the special Grand jury's report will
now be made public just as the Fulton
County district attorney Fannie Willis
is considering whether she will seek
indictments decisions are imminent
Willis oppose the release of the full
report arguing it could compromise the
ongoing investigation as media
organizations including CBS push for
more disclosure the investigation was
first sparked by an hour long January
2021 phone call where former president
Trump asked Georgia Secretary of State
Republican Brad raffensberger to find
the votes to win him Georgia look Brad I
gotta get I have to find
12 000 votes and I have them
raffensberger was among 75 Witnesses who
testified including longtime Trump
attorney Rudy Giuliani South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham and Georgia
Governor Brian Kemp the grand jury
looked into a push by Trump allies to
have so-called alternate electors
presented to Congress to block the
certification of President Biden's
election pressuring Fulton County
elections worker Ruby Freeman to falsely
admit to tampering as she explained in
testimony before the January 6 committee
do you
put false allegations of widespread
fraud by Trump allies the district
attorney and her team are truly looking
under every Stone Gwen Keys Fleming a
former County district attorney in
Georgia says Willis could be looking at
a variety of charges potentially even
for former president Trump who has
repeatedly denied any wrongdoing there
is a substantial likelihood of some real
criminal or possible criminal liability
here
here's how this could play out if the
district attorney decides to proceed
then a regular grand jury would issue
indictments in the coming weeks or
months meanwhile former president Trump
continues to face several legal
challenges as he once again seeks the
Republican Presidential nomination Gail
all right Bob thank you very much